hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday december 13th
2021 what's going on
yeah
how you doing what's going on with you
do you feel like you're in a rut
you just doing the same [__] [__] day
in and day out year after year
do you got the holiday blues
i do
my dumb ass this year was like you know
what i'm gonna [__] do i'm gonna get
all this holiday [__] out of the way
gonna get all the gifts done everything
wrapped everything bing bang boom go
[__] yourself
um it was good for stress
but then you just kind of left with you
you kind of left to be with your own
thoughts
of like ah jesus i just start doing math
how [__] old i am um it's just it's
it's not good
it's not good and then that's when i
know but the old me the old me
not saying i'm not old the old me right
who's my buddy was joking the other day
was is actually the younger you
um
would it just
let those thoughts wash over me and i
would just go down to the bottom of the
lagoon
and just lay there for a few weeks
instead i just go you know what i'm
doing i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go for a walk
damn
i'm gonna go play some drums
yeah
you know what happens when you get all
your christmas shopping done too soon
you start thinking [__] like what
happens when you die
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know i don't know what's
going on sorry um i'm fighting i'm
fighting it man fighting it off
um
congratulations by the way
by the way congratulations to max
verstappen
who won the formula one championship the
first non-english non-german driver
since kimmy uh
raikkonen is how you say his name it's
only a legend who retired today in 2007.
um
[__] crazy race i'm really beginning
to believe that formula one it's like
the nfl you know when there's a fumble
after a catch
and it's like did he or did he not make
a football move and to this day i i
still don't know what the [__] of
football did he tuck it in
did he start to make the same silhouette
as the heisman trophy that is a football
move
the knee's coming up but if you see the
arm is still down
now his wrist needs to be above his
waist and his knee has to be above his
hip flexor
to constitute like what in the [__]
is a football
move and i'm starting to feel like
formula one is i i don't understand the
[__] rules
um
you know i was losing my [__] in the
beginning the race like turned six
on the very first lap lewis hamilton had
a great start
and uh max went aggressively into this
turn and louis really had no choice
other than to just go off the track
which i didn't have a problem with
and then he just sort of got back on the
track uh max was max was gonna pass him
and then
lewis went off the track and diagonally
got back on the track and then was in
first place again and but he had a way
bigger lead than he had before
and allegedly slowed down a little bit
and made up for whatever advantage he
had of going off the track and i was
just like i don't think he did
and then he just sort of had this
gigantic lead throughout you know
double-digit lead it seemed like 10 11
12 13 seconds
and i gotta hand it to red bull red bull
did every [__] thing they possibly
could
in case something crazy happened so that
they would be in a position to take
advantage of it
i think they did three pit stops or
something
they pitted early and i think they went
to a hard tire
to try you know drive crazy and catch up
with them and uh i want to say they put
it again i don't remember my kids were
running around and all that [__] but
then um anyway
it just looks like did all of a sudden
there's eight laps left lewis has this
lead their car is great lewis is driving
amazing as always
he's out there in that clean air and
he's he's lapping people
and all of a sudden in the back of the
race there was an accident
which brought out
the uh whatever the pace car or
something so they're driving around
behind it and it's basically lewis
hamilton
four cars that have been lapped
and then
max verstappen so
there was oh by the end there was only
there was like two laps left
and all of a sudden out of nowhere the
stewards
decided that the lapped cars could go in
front of lewis hamilton
making max verstappen then right behind
lewis he didn't have to fight through
all of that traffic
which was great for the fans but during
that that caution max verstappen went in
and got on a soft tire and i was
wondering why
lewis hamilton didn't maybe he was in
first and was like
well i can't pit because if i pit he's
just gonna go and then he'll be in first
place
let's stay out here i don't know what
happened
but red bull team brought him in stuck
him on the soft tire
which is way more sticky than the medium
or the heart i guess and uh
yeah and then they let the lap traffic
go ahead for the restart
and max just had a way better grip
than lewis and it uh took a couple turns
he went past him and once he went past
him there was like one or two times that
maybe he thought lewis was going to get
him and then that was it and max
verstappen ended up winning it
and uh
i got to say lewis hamilton was a total
class act as was his dad went over and
shook hands with max and his dad but uh
as much as i was rooting for max
verstappen
and lewis hamilton drives me nuts where
i feel like he's a [__] all like an
all-star
nba player where they're never gonna get
called for an offensive file
um
i don't know about that
i don't understand why did they i still
don't understand why they let those cars
go
uh it was just a weird [__] way
if it was brilliant racing by
strategy by red bull
to just keep trying to you know give
themselves the best odds they just kept
doing that
but uh that was a really weird
it was weird i'm not it was [__]
weird so um
it was an amazing year i missed most of
it i was so [__] busy um
but uh congratulations to formula one on
an incredible season that literally came
down to the last lap
um i was convinced
you know in the end i go that lewis
hamilton and mercedes are gonna [__]
and they're gonna reverse this thing i
was convinced that that was gonna happen
it has not happened yet so
um i don't know what
did david stern start uh
take over f1 where he's decided that
they needed a celtics lakers thing to
get it [__] going again so they i
don't have no idea
um
a rivalry or some [__] i have no idea
anyway but it was an amazing race that's
what i watched today and i'll tell you
something else underrated
you know when your team has a bye week
just not watching any football
patriots were off this week and i didn't
watch one [__] second
of nfl football and i actually i went
out and i really enjoyed
my day i went out i did a um
this guy was doing a documentary on a
comedian and asked me to be in it
and uh they were shooting out in malibu
and it was like it was like to be honest
with you it was a perfect day to fly
and i was kind of hoping i was going to
get a chance to do that afterwards i
brought all of my [__] with me but um
this thing went longer than i
anticipated but it was just an amazing
uh
an amazing um
i don't know just like gig to do like
usually a documentary you sit down you
[__] or whatever
uh but the way that they did this thing
was really unique i'm not gonna say what
they did
but um
it was you know showing me comedy clips
that i had seen before and now just
being older looking at them
and seeing the in-between of the jokes
was pretty [__] cool so
i'll let you know when that thing comes
out but uh
you know i did miss a couple of kid
birthday parties today which sucked
uh my wife took my daughter around to
them and um
i missed one yesterday because i was
down in san diego
so
you know today i made sure like tonight
ever you know what the big good thing is
no matter how much how busy i get always
from five to seven every night is my
time with my kids
and we run around the living room and
all that type of stuff we have a good
time
and my daughter's getting good about
letting me watch can hey can we watch
some daddy tv now
and you she's usually he's just like no
you know wanted to watch some [__]
what the [__] does she watch
those [__] dogs with the watches
um
what the [__] are they paw patrol
she's all about that [__]
she usually wants to watch that right
so tonight she actually let me put on so
i thought i was going to put on a little
bit of that packers bears game and then
60 minutes was on i'm like well let's
see what they're talking about they did
this whole [__] thing on this island
off in newfoundland
in canada
and this woman that built this [__]
hotel out there
that brought tourism to this dying
island but then it's sort of a love hate
that they have with it and stuff and
but she told this heartbreaking story
about how her dad was a fisherman
and could make a living and feed the
family and all that and then one day
the
commercial [__] corporate boats came
in
and they just took all the fish
and he came home
after fishing the whole day
and had one fish
and just threw it on the floor and said
it's [__] over and the next day he
burned his boat and told his daughter to
learn about money
you better learn this money game because
this is what this is about and it was
just like wow
you know it was sort of uh the beginning
of the
the big like what what cities and
everything are now it's like
they just [__] take everything over
it's really [__] horrible
um
then i was also looking at going wait a
minute those fishermen that you know
they got [__] over there was
originals i believe that that's what
they call
their people up there
they were probably there first
you know
at some point they threw a [__]
fish on the ground said it's [__]
over the white people are coming i don't
know the whole [__] thing it's just i
don't know you know there's somebody you
know maybe this is why i'm in like this
funk is one of you guys sent me this
video that i watched
called rules for rulers it's 20 minutes
and it explains how power works
within a democracy versus a dictatorship
and everything and it's all kind of uh
you know the same thing where at work
all of us who aren't in power are
basically peasants where you get to be
you know
you know democracy's the smartest
because they treat their peasants the
best
and then there's also a chance for a
peasant to become rich
you know and then that's what everybody
chases that's like the lottery they go
and they see somebody like you know he
was standing right where i was standing
he put his head down he went to work he
died it's still a great thing
about the capitalistic system but like
um
i don't know everybody that i know
i know a number of people that are in
that corporate world like just what that
[__] does to you
you know having people work through the
goddamn holidays
and you don't want to do it you want to
tell your boss to go [__] himself but
you know if you do there's someone
waiting in the wings that doesn't give a
[__]
you know
and then it's funny and then the boss
goes all right well you're you you know
you want to be home with your family
[__] you you're fired then he promotes
that animal that doesn't give a [__]
it's that it's the holidays and in the
back of his head he's got to think this
guy's like such an animal one day maybe
he's gonna come from my throat
you know
it's [__] exhausting
it really is
so um
yeah so check that out watch uh rules
for rulers
really a fascinating thing
and then i watched this great um
i watched this great french movie called
close enemies on netflix
uh
i don't know made me want to get back
into uh trying to learn you know
get a little further with my french this
time i was surprised by how many words i
still remembered but there was a bunch
that i forgot but
uh just a great movie and it starts off
like you know
all right i'm gonna take it out of this
genre so i don't ruin it
all right it would be like uh
[Music]
like a trope what they call it right
like take like a cop
you know he plays by his own rules and
you know this is going to be the scene
where he [__] up early in the beginning
you know and his superior makes him turn
in his gun and his badge
you know
but then you know now he's suspended but
he still works on the case and in the
end he proves himself right maybe
there's a corrupt politician that's
literally
i think one of the dirty harry's
um
that's just that style has been done so
many times they basically take a story
like that a relationship like that that
has been done a zillion times
and
they just throw a big left [__] turn
in it and you're like oh my god now
what's gonna happen
like i'd say the first time i remember
seeing that
was uh
maybe to live and die in l.a
um
had something like that and then there
was a movie called uh sexy beast which
is one of my favorite movies of all time
and what i love about that movie is
there's so many gangster movies
that
um the whole plot is just like okay
these two old gangsters and they're
gonna do one more job they just need to
do one more job and then they're gonna
retire you know of course a bunch of
[__] happens well that movie starts
with the gangsters retired they already
did the one more job and they're living
in paradise
and what could go wrong you know
and then
it goes from there you gotta see that
[__] movie
one of my favorites of all time um
and with that i want to thank everybody
that came out uh
down at harrah's just north east
of san diego
uh i went down there with todd rex what
do you say to handsome
and uh bianca chris davao
uh we all went down there we had a great
[__] time and uh both crowds were
awesome
and it was great to be back
you know out there on the road
you know i got my [__] booster shot
didn't get sick or nothing i never got
sick on any of the [__] things i feel
pretty good on all of that [__]
so uh you know
i'm [__] doing what they're telling
me to do we'll see we'll see what the
[__] happens
who knows who knows hey by the way
what's the college playoff now
playoff
who's michigan going to play they
playing cincinnati
uh
college football
playoff
college football playoff
why is my internet so goddamn slow oh i
know why
cause i'm on the wrong one
you are not connected
you are not connected to the internet
college football playoff all right
scheduled date
news about georgia michigan alabama or
is it it's not cincinnati who the [__]
is else is in it
let's see here
look at all of this goddamn
information
i mean look at it
for god's sakes look at it
who the [__] is in it this year all
right
lucas oil stadium indianapolis indiana
is where the national championship
location it's going to be in los angeles
in 2023.
holy [__] i gotta go
i gotta go to that the college football
super bowl and then in 2024
it's going to be in in in in
uh nrg stadium in houston texas
well i'm trying to figure out who the
[__] playing this year why is that so
difficult all right number one's alabama
so they're gonna play number four
cincinnati
and then hail to the victors number two
michigan plays georgia
that's gonna be a tough game
what do you guys think huh
do you think the big ten's overrated
again are they gonna go down there and
get smacked all around by the [__]
sec
oh those big corn fed [__]
gonna run it down their goddamn throat
set michigan offensive line i'll tell
you right now if i had to run and i buy
a [__] goddamn offensive line that's
the line i want to run up right behind
i'll tell you right now you got to say
that you got to say that when you're
doing color commentating i'll tell you
right now
you know
there's about two or three guys in the
league that can do what you what you
just saw there there is you cannot teach
that
i know i know
it can you somehow teach you not to
[__] say that every time
can you do that
um
yeah i don't know um so i had a great
time down in san diego and i was when i
was driving down there
you know we were cutting through uh east
l.a because of um
you know all the traffic and [__] and i
swear to god
i don't know if i got the picture over
here yeah
just on a side street just the [__]
cars and how long that they they survive
out here
i saw a dually dodge there was 70 or 71
dodge i ended up figuring out what the
[__] it was like a dump truck
a dodge
[__] dump truck
50 [__] years old
let me see let me see i sent this to
somebody
i don't know what the [__] is going on
here
with my damn phone ever since i did that
last [__] update my phone is what my
phone is doing is what everybody was
telling me i was what's gonna happen to
me if i got the vaccine
this [__] thing is going nuts
all right let's see here if i can find
this thing
all right i sent it to my buddy here
there it is
early 70s dodge i was in east l.a
look at that beaut it's a six-wheel
[__] dump truck
i mean it looks like it's four-wheel
drive it's [__] gigantic
never seen one of those in my life i've
seen you know the old fords and i've
seen the old chevys and dodge was just
they they just were never in the game
when it came to trucks in like the 60s
you know and then in the 70s i just felt
like they were so far behind they had no
respect in the 80s they finally came up
with at least a name they came up with
the dodge ram
and then they actually made like a a
mid-sized truck i think was called the
dakota
and um
but it was always the argument like what
do you like better the chevy silverado
you know a gmc
or a uh you know a ford f-150 or f-250
and and they were always the also until
they came up with that killer front end
um and like the dodge hemi and all of
that [__] all right i'm always babbling
about trucks here let's talk uh let's do
a little advertising here shall we
um all right look who it is everybody
it's butcherbox
you know when it comes to the meat that
will be the centerpiece of your holiday
meals quality matters
and when you invest in high quality meat
ladies from butcher box the benefits go
way beyond a great tasting meal butcher
box sources their meat from partners
with the highest standards for quality
no more searching the grocery store for
100 grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild caught alaskans seafood
wild caught seafood and more
uh their sourcing decisions are made
holistically
keeping the farmer the planet the animal
and your family in mind all right i love
that [__] pork man
i like that [__] i also like that deal
where you get [__] bacon in every
goddamn box every month butcher box
ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to your home free
shipping
for the continental u.s no antibiotics
or added hormones each box contains 8 to
14 pounds of meat ladies depending on
the box you choose that's enough for 24
individual meals packed fresh and
shipped frozen for convenience so you
can save time on your next grocery store
trip customize your own box or go to
with one of theirs either way you get
exactly what you want this holiday
butcher box is giving new members one
pack of bacon for free
in every box plus twenty dollars off
each box for the first five months
of your membership that's free bacon for
life
and up to a hundred dollars off sign up
at butcherbox.com
slash that's butcherbox.com
all right
what do we got here oh policy genius
everybody all right this one here you
know
if you're gonna die someday you should
listen to this here if someone relies on
your financial support
in other words
is there a woman in your life that is
air quote
overseeing
the landscaping in your backyard
a woman that is managing the house
that's one of my favorite things ever
when a rich guy gets divorced
and the woman who just laid around and
didn't do [__] all of a sudden she has
to make it look like she did something
in the relationship so just laying
around the house becomes like these
corporate positions
i oversaw the redesign of the pool
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's [__] hilarious all right if
someone relies on your financial support
whether it's a child aging parent or
even a business partner you need life
insurance life insurance can give you
peace of mind
if something happens to you your loved
ones would have a financial cushion to
pay for things like rent mortgage
payments loans education costs and
everyday expenses having coverage you
got to do that dude if you [__] croak
you got to make sure everybody's you
know everybody gets a nice water [__]
cash like jimmy the jet just walked into
to take all you [__] grease balls
money oh
um having cur coverage
through your job may not be enough most
people need as much as 10 times more to
properly provide for their families
typically life insurance gets more
expensive as you age so it starts to get
a policy uh so smart to get a policy
sooner rather than later yeah i learned
that the hard way how it works head to
policygenius.com and answer a few quick
questions about yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genes their licensed experts will
help you understand your options and
apply for a policy the policy genius
team works for you not the insurance
companies uh you can trust them to offer
unbiased help and advocate for you at
every step until you're covered policy
genius doesn't add on extra fees or sell
your info to third parties that's nice
of them
head to policygenius.com to get your
free life insurance quotes and see how
much you could save that's policy
genius.com
and lastly but not leastly
ladies and gentlemen
it's the star of the day who will it
be their name may hold the key it's up
to you to tell us who will be star of
the day what the [__] was that that was
something
i was on like after [__] candlepins
for cash when i was a kid uh stamps.com
everybody let you compare rates
print labels and access exclusive
discounts on ups and united states
postal services
um all year long it just makes sense
especially if your business sends more
mail and packages during the holidays
you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over nine years now and if you haven't
tried it the [__] are you waiting for
how many years do i gotta run my yap
over here uh whether you're selling
online or running an office or a side
hustle
stamps.com can save you so much time
money and stress during the holidays
access all the post office and ups
shipping services you need without
taking the trip
and get discounts you can't find
anywhere else like up to 40 off all usps
united states postal service rates and
up to 76 percent off all united uh
parcel service ups going to the post
office instead of using stamps.com is
kind of like taking the stairs instead
of the elevator
uh save time and money this holiday
season with stamps.com sign up with the
promo code burr for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and enter the code burp i
got the hiccups
um that's kind of a funny analogy huh
it's like taking the stairs instead of
using the elevator all right well taking
the stairs you know that's better for
your [__] heart it's better for your
legs
you know
and if you wipe out all you do is fall
down one flight of stairs till you hit
the landing you know
things go wrong in an elevator i'll tell
you depending on where you are that can
be a rough one okay
um
all right sorry
my apologies let's try to be a little
more serious here well that's why you go
to policy genius
go to policy genius then you don't have
to worry about taking the [__] stairs
you can just [__] be eating a burger
and fries drinking a milkshake
waiting for the [__] uh elevator
you know
all right jokes from china okay let's do
a little backstory here
i love when people write in from other
countries
all right
i do
and this is the thing even though
that i know i'm better than you because
i'm an american
[Music]
i still like to hear from you because it
gives me an opportunity to pretend that
i'm like empathetic
uh no i'm kidding um
i got some uh you know i've gotten some
letters from mainland china which just
blows me away because over here in the
united states all america here thomas
jefferson and all them powdered wigs
sons of [__]
um they make it seem like you guys um
can't listen to any anything from over
here uh with your censored internet
which i have to be honest with you i
don't think it's such a bad idea you
know i remember before i was thinking
wow it's [__] up they don't let them
talk to each other and blah blah blah
blah but if you see how batshit crazy
some people are going over here going on
the internet meeting and talking to
other batshit crazy people on the
[__] internet um
you know out of all the mistakes i've
made i got to tell you something one of
the best things i ever did is i never
really talked to anybody on the internet
i mean i'll send out a tweet that's the
closest i come to talking to anybody
you know but like i've never gone into a
chat room and been like hey they're
[__] 1976
uh hashtag you know whatever
you know where you're living and like
get to know somebody that's just [__]
weird
um anyway so i was just whatever
i got some uh emails from china
so i was like you know if anybody out
there in china is listening i'd love to
hear from you
i was talking about all the [__] up
things
all the [__] up jokes that we've had
about people from china and and the
stuff that we've done in movies and tv
just you know offensive [__] so i was
like you can't tell me you guys don't
have jokes about americans let me hear
some of your jokes from china making fun
of somebody like me
uh over here in america so here we go
jokes from china hello billy fat tits
long time listener first time mailer
just heard
your podcast
that asking some jokes about america
from china my name is han
solo
my name is han and i'm chinese and i
have some jokes about it so here we go
when i was in new york i lived in the
most dangerous and dirty place in
manhattan it was called it's called
chinatown i found it
uh i found it
i found americans are very lazy at
naming things okay
like chinese live together they call it
chinatown korea goes together it's
called koreatown white people go
together it's called brunch oh jesus
that's doing jokes here it's very lazy
that kind of thing will never happen if
americans come to asia
dude this guy's literally doing stand-up
hey i'll tell you when i was in new york
i lived in the most dangerous and dirty
place was called chinatown okay
oh well that was rough it was rough down
in chinatown i found america's very lazy
name of things
a bunch of chinese get together they're
called chinatown koreans go to come
together they're called koreatown white
people coming together it's called
brunch oh i'll tell you that's a beaut
um that kind of thing will never happen
oh this is this yakov smirnoff
in america you call it branch in russia
it's called eggs
that kind of thing will never happen if
americans come to asia if a group of
americans americans go to japan and live
in japan
the japanese wouldn't call it american
town
they just call it a military base
[Music]
[Laughter]
those are some good jokes
that's it i hope you enjoy it and love
from shanghai china best wishes hand cue
how about a round of applause for hank
you writing some respectable stand-up
comedy in a second language hats off to
you that was [__] that's some good
[__]
i feel like johnny carson that's good
stuff that's good stuff
i love it
all right hand cue has set the bar
asia
come on what is that 90 billion of you
over there you can't tell me i want to
hear from the david tells and louis cks
and dave chappelles of china
i want to hear you i want to start
roasting america i want to i want to
start doing some [__] jokes here
all right
uh
okay here we go old man dirt bike all
right so lately um
i've had this desire you know i was
going over to the airport flying my
little [__] uh whirlybird or whatever
and um
i was just thinking like you know what
i'd love to get a dirt bike i could just
ride it around the airport there's
nobody really there it's a small [__]
airport i could ride safely i could
still keep the skill and knowing how to
ride a motorcycle or whatever and i
wouldn't have to worry about getting
t-boned by somebody staring at their
phone in a [__] tesla [__] tesla
dude
it's all electric you see the bottom of
it it's a giant [__] battery
all right old man dirt bike dear billy
milky tits uh i sent you this email over
a year ago i'm even more in love with
the yamaha
wr2 250r than before yeah i looked it up
i guess this this bike is discontinued
um i think it is i don't know i have
many friends that have switched from the
ktm because they don't need the
performance and hate the maintenance
my brother is your age and has been
riding a dirt bike his whole life he lo
he loves
uh his wr more than anything he's ever
had it's street legal can go about 80
miles per hour
uncomfortably but rips off road i'm
almost 100 percent off road nowadays the
best thing about this bike maintenance
oil changes are every 3000 miles
and it doesn't need a valve adjustment
for 18 000 miles this is unheard of for
dirt bikes ktms and most two-strokes
need oil changes every 16 hours or so
[__] a two-stroke i don't need to do
that
i'm not trying to go like nine million
miles an hour and the environment is
imploded enough
i'm doing a four stroke
uh yeah they're faster but this thing is
plenty quick for me uh it's light enough
that i was even able to lift it into my
truck alone in a pinch no ramp i love
this bike
that i b uh i love this bike that i
bought a friend a bike to keep in my
garage so i can tempt out of towners to
come ride with me my brother and best
friend got them too i know you never
take me up on it but you're welcome to
borrow it if you're ever in san
francisco and this covered [__] dies
down don't mess with the two-stroke oil
injection it's just a mess
all right few non-gear heads out there
like me i i looked this up a long time
ago
um
difference between a two-stroke and a
four-stroke
is you know when the piston gets to the
top of the cylinder
uh and the spark plug hits
you know igniting the the gas and air
mixture the emulsion of gas in in oxygen
that explosion is what drives the piston
down and turns the crankshaft
so in a true two-stroke
that happens every time the piston comes
up so two-stroke okay it goes down
after the explosion and comes back up
another explosion down two strokes down
up down up every time it goes up
the uh spark plug fires on a four-stroke
it fires it goes down it comes up it
goes down it comes back up and it fires
again that's simply it so basically
it fires half as much times on a
four-stroke so there's not as much
fumes and all that [__] coming out the
back of the bike however with the
two-stroke it's just constantly [__]
cranking
slamming that piston down turning the
crankshaft and you got all of this power
uh all that says with the size of my
head that just means i'm gonna fly off
the back of the bike
[Laughter]
so um
anyway i i looked up some of those
yamahas and uh you know they still seem
kind of expensive um
i don't need a ktm jesus christ
one of my evil knievel
or robbie knievel am i gonna jump from
once one [__] uh
casino to another
i don't need to be doing that [__] but i
uh
you know you know the reality is the
reality is it's just once in my life i
want to drive
a harley road king
down some [__] road like in [__]
montana or just in the middle of [__]
nowhere
uh
is sort of
the dream
but like it's just too [__] scary i
told you guys i had a bike for like two
months out here
and uh you know me i'm not a religious
guy
and i took that thing out one time
and i you know my dream was to go down
sunset and take it all the way to the
beach and i did that and i went around a
turn somewhere where the old playboy
mansion used to be
and this guy came over the double line
just a little bit and i was in a turn
and i had to stand it up so he wouldn't
take my [__] head off and it was just
a split second but it felt like
it felt like
i was you know gonna go right into the
trees or lose my head
and i remember when we finally got to
the beach i was riding with dean and i
got off the bike and i was like shaking
and i was thinking like is that from the
vibration of the bike like what's going
on i was like low level shaking it's
like oh no that's because i almost just
died
so i just made a promise i said god if
you get me back to dean's garage
i will never [__] ride a motorcycle
in la ever again
and uh i didn't i parked it and i said
sell this [__] thing
[Laughter]
um
riding a bike i tell you it's not as fun
as you think it's gonna be
because you're so busy trying not to get
killed you don't get to look at anything
um where i feel like
you know
i don't know i have like a four-wheeler
and i [__] zip around the airport and
i have a [__] blast on that thing
you know
i slow down the intersections i know
somebody could become but there's really
nobody there
i just do it every once in a while keep
the battery nice and charged you know
i'll just [__] take it through the
gears and [__] like that and i have a
[__] blast on that thing
and um it's because
i don't have to worry about getting
[__] hit by anybody where the second
i get on the road it's like oh jesus oh
jesus where's it coming where's it
coming from
um
so yeah i'm gonna get one
[__] it i'm gonna get one the yamaha
wr250r huh
all right i'll look at i i mean i'm
loving that no maintenance
i mean that is just just like you said
old man dirt bike that's what the [__]
i'm talking 250 it's not a lot of power
it's a [__] four stroke doesn't need
any maintenance that's perfect
[__] brilliance missing is training
wheels i mean that is just right up my
alley
that's exactly it i'm not trying to
[__]
you know learn how to do wheelies or
anything like that i just want to
[__]
ride around on it all right rounding up
change
uh hey bill
what's this new [__]
i drive through to pay
to pay get food
instead of giving me change they asked
if i want to round up the change to the
nearest dollar
because of the coin shortage
the bill was 94 cents so they want you
to eat the extra 53 cents yeah tell them
to go [__] themselves i haven't heard
about that
that sounds like a scam
dude these people incorporate they're
just [__] they're criminals
if anybody out there is living a life of
crime just you just start donating to
politicians
and start advertising
your criminal enterprise
on a news network and i'm telling you
you will we won't have any [__]
problems rounding up
change
scam
let's see what we get here
why so many companies are rounding up
your spare change
what does this mean okay
last week
taxi app lift took out a full page ad
and then sunday new york times tuned out
a magnanimous new program it will soon
rolled out called roundup and donate oh
[__] you donate you [__] [__] you're
gonna donate one percent of it and line
your pockets with the change you [__]
this is the oldest scam out there
opt in and will automatically round up
your fare to the next whole dollar and
push the difference towards issues
impacting everyone everywhere from
climate change to the pursuit of
equality could it be any more just just
vague
yes it's fair to see it as another
effort to capitalize while uber its
biggest competitor has been beset by
scandals
for nearly two months straight and the
language of the ad
sit for something it's what lyft was
founded on
led to led many to roll their eyes the
new york observers said the ad is really
a big [__] you to ober
ober
uber while an ad week reporter wrote on
twitter you're you're a ride share
company get over yourself exactly all
right let's see what were the scandals i
didn't see this
all right uber head has had five major
scandals in just two weeks
you know who would have thought just
getting in a in a car with a complete
stranger where there's nothing that vets
them
that eventually you would have a problem
an extended i mean if i was a serial
killer i would just become an uber
driver
you know
are you sick of throwing having to run
down and tackle victims
all that money you spend on chloroform
and all that money on rags
wouldn't it be great if your victim
would just get in your car
introducing uber
um an extended string of bad news about
uber continued on friday with with a new
york times report that uber has used for
years a surreptitious data tool to
deceive authorities in unfriendly
markets
it was only oh my these guys should be
in [__] jail
they got enough money to stay out of
jail it was only one month ago that the
hashtag delete uber began trending
during protests to presidents trump's
travel ban
well what the [__] does trump have to do
with uber leading ceo travis kalanick to
step down from trump's business council
oh i see
oh because he was with trump
oh i get it but if he was with joe biden
people would be like all right it's okay
he could stay with uber is that how it
works uh but that already feels like
eons are going eons ago
in the time since uber has been at the
center of an additional five scandals
that has brought more negative scrutiny
on the hot taxi company they're not a
taxi which was already no stranger to
scandal
than ever before all right that's even
more links how the company deals with
each of these storms could determine
what [__] storms
do these people get paid by the [__]
word
all right
former employee bombshell blog post on
february 19th
susan fowler rigetti a former uber
engineer now working on
wrote an eye-opening blog what did she
say
alleging she received repeated sexual
advances from a male colleague
well this isn't uber's fault
you know what i mean this is this is on
the guy that does it why does that go
down to the company
like are you supposed to say in the hey
before we hire you do you plan on uh
taking your dick out at work well yeah
actually i did all right we can't hide
like it's that simple
after the blog post went live and
quickly rocketed
around the internet yeah because of all
these stupid uh air quote news sites
not because they give a [__] because
they know that people will read [__]
like that and they can make money with
banner ads
uh
kalanick not colonic kalanick said in a
statement uh
what follow describes is a horn and
against everything uber stands for and
believes in that's [__] hilarious
that you even need to say that
i mean when uber came out it's like
we want to have more affordable taxis
and we are against taking your dick out
and shaking it at women that you work
with just want to throw that in there as
a as an aside
um
okay but only three days later a deep
dive in new york time story on uber's
culture suggested that contrary to what
colonic kalanick said fowler's story is
not at all
contrary to what uber believes in
you're telling me uber believes in
sexual harassment or they had a couple
of the employees
time stories sighting with more than 30
current and former employ uber employees
concluding that uber's workplace's his
culture is aggressive and unrestrained
[Laughter]
who would do it think you know just such
a simple idea
i mean business is brutal
what's my name [__] you who would think
that they would have some glenn gary
glenn ross [__] going on there
um
this is going to be funny in the future
when women run everything
and then guys will [__] like this and
it'll be like
the female run uber has been described
as caddy and rumor starting
um
the level of cuntiness in the office is
just completely unacceptable
sorry um all right
hang on a second that hey i got
completely got off the subject here this
is rounding up
would you like to round up
this is so so br a brilliant way to mug
people with the with
their consent
because people don't like change anymore
it's a question would you like to round
up
it's a question many cashiers are asking
customers around the st louis region i
feel like one of those [__] pm
magazine guys right now
like i'm doing the voice over this is
showing footage of somebody at a [__]
stomping shop
uh would you like to round up it's often
asked as you're checking out at the
store or paying at a drive through local
grocery stores fast food restaurants and
even pet stores offer customers a chance
to make charitable donations at checkout
news 4's chris nangus was recently asked
if he wanted to round up at a missouri
taco bell he told he was told his 48
cent donation would benefit education
and students
it might not seem like a lot but
according to tax filings with the irs
the taco bell foundation brought in
millions of dollars through the
generosity of its customers and how many
more millions they keep according to its
2018-19 uh 990 forum the taco bell
foundation brought in nearly 14 million
dollars
well let's stop here how about a round
of applause for taco bell
they donated 14 million dollars
to uh to benefit education and students
while also
taking out millions of people with heart
attacks
so they get rid of people which is great
for the environment and then they're
trying to help the ones who survive
their food be even smarter it's amazing
joe waters runs selfish giving
oh wow it's a is that an oxymoron um
an organization that helps businesses
business partners with non-profits to
raise money at the point of sale
they're becoming really popular walter
said he said a recent partnership with
an east coast chain with 120 locations
brought in approximately forty fifty
thousand dollars worth of roundup
donations in just three weeks
geez half a million dollars in just
three weeks everybody and that's just
what they reported
oh my god
jesus christ that's that didn't richard
pryor do that in one of the superman
movies
it was like a half a cent left over from
everybody's check and the next thing you
know he showed up in a ferrari
rest his soul the greatest of all time
um all right give them the sun
hey billy fat tits periodically i hear
you talk about jesus i'm getting all i'm
getting all fat shamed here you
[__] periodically i hear you
talking about your solution to the
middle east conflicts you talk about the
tensions over natural resources
specifically oil reserves and offer a
simple solution well i'm a simple man
sir
give him the sun yeah give the oil
companies control of the sun
that's it now solar energy is great in
all
but there's been a recent breakthrough
in nuclear fusion technology nuclear
power plants that exist today operate
operate using nuclear fission
fission splits atoms whereas fusion
smooshes them together
i like how he's using [__]
bar room logic so he doesn't lose me
here the process of nuclear fusion is
similar to what goes on in the actual
sun so your dream just might become a
reality i'll pause here if you want to
do some googling i'm all for whatever
creates
cleaner air and less waste the only
thing i'm worried about
anything nuclear is
the waste and how long it lasts and what
what the [__] you do with it
you know knowing full well that you know
all of these [__] solar panels and
all of that [__] also the amount of raw
material it takes to make those things
aren't exactly green either but my thing
is to just get the [__] out of the
middle east
you know what i mean so those people
over there can just get back to [__]
you know
it was like they were having a nice
battle royal over there and then like
wrestling we came running out of the
[__] locker room i think it's time to
go back in the locker room and let
people handle their own goddamn business
over there
uh this new technology has been a pipe
dream for 30 years
and up until very recently it had been
thought to be 30 years
30 plus years off so this is big news
big news you hear that all you [__]
people who think that nobody's cured
anything or done anything and [__]
since polio i love this my favorite
[__] analogy that they haven't cured
anything since polio it's like well
maybe the real thing is you haven't been
paying attention
um this is big news uh the main benefit
of fusion is that it has minimal waste
uses fuel that is abundant and is much
more stable as compared to fission
fission factors well that is exciting
anyway thought you might find that
interesting and i hope to hear your
thoughts on the show as with many others
i listen to every episode and love the
show thanks for all the laughs the
entertainment you provide to us on a
regular basis no problem that is
exciting that is the kind of thing
that actually sounds like it's too good
to be true and it's going to be
fascinating to watch how we somehow [__]
it up
um
i mean there we go right there
if what you're saying is true this is a
way out
sorry it did a couple shows my voice
always cracks when i do a couple of
shows
um all right oh god and just when we had
hope just when we were starting to feel
better just when we got some of the
great stand-up comedy greatest stand-up
comedy ever heard from mainland china
by the great
keep it going one more time for han q
everybody
dude i swear to god if i ever do stand
up
in shanghai
if you want to come on in front of me
and do five minutes all right
you got the gig all right buddy all
right
just don't get yourself a left arrested
all right
hey i did i did stand up in mainland
china oh hotel that was a rough one
the opening act did a joke they ran them
over with a tank okay
um all right give them the sun i already
read that one okay the collapse of the
public educational system oh jesus here
we go uh dear bill i am a junior in a
public high school in los angeles
and this and the state at which my
fellow students operate has vastly
deteriorated over the course of the
pandemic and nobody seems to be talking
about it well i'm glad you're talking
about it because people should know
about it over the last two years while
my classes were online every student got
bailed out of their bad grades because
it was just blamed on quarantine
well where the [__] was that when i was
going to school uh we were just given a
pass or fail grade based
off
of our report card
before quarantine started
uh this should have not been announced
because as soon as my classmates figured
this out they immediately stopped doing
any work and we just sit around playing
video games all day oh
oh wow
let me read that again because i kind of
[__] up the reading of that word that
sentence we were just given a pass or
failed grade based off of our report
card before quarantine started
uh this should not have been announced
because as soon as my classmates figured
this out they immediately stopped doing
any work and would just sit around
playing video games all day
they would just keep their cameras and
microphones off or not even join the
meeting fully in our zoom meetings
which took the place of in-class
instruction
very few people actually attended class
and nobody learned anything this current
school year came
and we went back to our real life class
all the teachers expected the slackers
to start working again they didn't this
entire semester a lot of students
haven't made the connection that their
grades now matter attendance is way down
and very little is done in class and
nobody does the assigned work
i am in an advanced program at my school
and i believe a lot of my classmates are
going to fail out of it yeah but you're
not
don't do what those knuckleheads are
doing my question is
should lausd la unified school district
bail all of the slackers out of their
bad grades again this year or do you
think they should draw the line and say
they should get their act together
um thank you for your seemingly endless
amount of relationship advice you have
helped me and my buddies out a bunch oh
that's nice p.s i hope this finds you
because i have zero [__] idea how to
reach you well you figured it out um
okay
you asked me do you think they should
draw the line and say they should have
they should have gotten their act
together
um
i think they should take a portion of
the blame
the public should take a portion of the
blame and the students should take a
portion of the blame we should all
focus on this
i think this would be a good thing with
all the [__]
flapping in the arms and chicken little
[__] going on out there
you know i think this is the most
important thing
is uh whatever is going on with the kids
the youth the next people
that are going to be coming along
you know
as an old guy i want you guys to be
you know doing the best you can and
having a better life than i've had like
that's what you're supposed to want as
an old person
so that sucks that it's like that and i
got to be honest with you i probably
would have fell into that
a little bit too
um
because i [__] hated school but you
know
i also hated getting yelled at and i
gotta tell you that's what my parents
did when i [__] brought home a bad
report card i was i would just get
[__] yelled at and it
you know it you know it is negative
motivation but it [__] works
so
i'm proud that you're still yet you
didn't fall into that [__] and um
you know you learned a uh a
valuable lesson early on in your life
um what you're seeing what these people
are doing your fellow classmates
is what a lot of people do in life
is they
find a way
to do as little as possible
and
it's why becoming successful
is not as hard as you would think it is
it's definitely a lot of work it's
definitely a lot of sacrifice
but you know as you're not really
competing with everybody
you know you're just competing with
other people that are working as hard as
you are
other than that most people
you know
not most i would say like you know like
i would say 30 of people
like
their dream in life
is to not do [__] and get paid
and they would be happy with that
like
they would want to be like a trust fund
kid
um
and then you have
the next 30 or so i think that they uh
they're good people and they work hard
but they don't necessarily have a
passion
and they kind of fall into something and
they do that and they you know they
enjoy it and they i don't know maybe
they get
more out of other things i don't know
what
you know those people that you know they
like their jobs whatever but they got a
boat you know they can't wait to take
the boat out you know or they got a dirt
bike or whatever they got just something
that they want to go [__] do
you know got vacation coming up oh my
god we're going down to the poconos you
know those people
and uh you know so you know it's really
i don't even know what it's like 20
of people is what you're [__]
competing with so
um congratulations
you know
succeeding is like an old school rocket
you know what i mean going up to the
moon and that first section drops off
that's what you just saw now there's
just two thirds of it left
and you want to make sure you're up
there in that top of that [__]
capsule there
so you can go plant your flag son
um
yeah i would love to do
be involved in anything that would help
out public schools
and help kids out
and uh i wish there was something you
could do like if they started a program
you know they had that dumb [__] no you
could [__] rescue a road or something
you know
you were responsible for keeping it
clean they had [__] like that something
like that they should do that with
schools you can pick if there's a like a
local school
there's like a way that even with your
busy life that you can be involved
and uh you know help raise money or go
down there clean up do something
you know
because that can't go away man the free
public education jesus christ grades 1
through 12.
i mean that's what that's what it was
all about
it's what it's all about that's where
you learn all the [__] lies man
uh prostitute man yay or nay
dear billy bong dong
you seeing my dick looks like a bong i
mean
all right i'll take that he got a glass
tube there
um hey bill i'm ripped off the jazz
cabbage right now
and i had to run an idea past you
is that an inside joke with you and your
friends i love how you just presented
that like i like that's a common is that
a common expression i'm ripped off the
jazz cabbage
i'm a 24 year old who's still who's
still a virgin
well congratulations you don't have any
stds
you're like one of those star wars
action figures that's still in the box
your [__] dick is worth money
um i don't think there's anything wrong
with virginity but i'm fixing to punch
that v card like it's a title fight
there you go i like it get up to bat
start swinging
uh the problem is i have no game with
the ladies
fellas and non-binary folks everyone's
on the table
i didn't have my first kiss until i was
22 and haven't gotten that far again i
got a birthday spanking from a dude at a
bdsm club that that wasn't a sexual
thing so it doesn't count
i love how you're a virgin but you're
going to a bondage
[__] place for your birthday i got a
feeling once you get in the game you're
gonna be gonna you're gonna be like
jordan it takes you two weeks to
establish yourself
in the league
anyway i got to thinking about saving up
money to visit a sex worker
to be clear i mean one of those legit
establishment where everything's on the
up and up and people like their job
nobody who has to [__] bang somebody
for a living likes their job i figure
once i lose my virginity and let the
wave of guilt instilled in me from my
religion slash upbringing hit me once i
get over it i'll be a bit more confident
and be able to develop some skills in
the art of seduction
uh
on top of that i feel like i'd be a it'd
be a dope experience
uh another virgin could blow my mind the
first time imagine a seasoned pro
who does the [__] okay uh for all
sayings if you went out and banged
another virgin where you're at that
would blow your mind but imagine if a
season pro does the [__] for a living uh
what do you think should i keep it and
uh the old-fashioned way or a tag in
a couple paper wingmen
uh thanks and go [__] someone else all
right first of all you have a great
sense of humor
so and you don't want to do that
you don't want you don't want to have
you don't want to do that don't go down
that [__] road uh
what you need to do is you have to do
what a stand-up comedian does
which you have to bomb your way into
knowing how to be a comedian so you have
to bomb your way into knowing how to hit
on chicks or whatever the [__] it is
you're into
all right um
so what you do is you set little
attainable goals every time you go out
you know i'm gonna hit on three chicks
that's it
i don't know what i'm gonna say but i'm
gonna have fun
and uh you know what's great about all
of this [__] is you're just gonna you're
gonna get some hilarious [__] stories
and uh
you know if you're 24 and you got
friends do they know you're a virgin if
they don't you should tell them
just be like listen man i'm still a
virgin and i'm sick of this [__] if any
you guys got any dude and guys were like
[__]
like the 40 year old virgin once they
found out steve carrell was a virgin
they were like we're gonna get this
[__] guy laid that's it
they're gonna help you out and uh you're
gonna be fine you got a great sense of
humor all right everybody likes to
[__] laugh
you're gonna be fine
you don't need to tap out and go you
know
that dark route don't don't don't be
doing that [__] you know
imagine that you you coming right out of
your box the first time
[__] luke skywalker comes out and
turns on his lightsaber and then you end
up getting some [__] std
um this is one of these legit places you
know where the people like their job now
they had horrible childhoods and that's
how the [__] they ended up in there
you don't want to be in that world at
all all right that's it so hang in there
don't take the easy way out
all right
talk some [__] have some fun allow
yourself to be a [__] idiot allow
yourself to not know what you're doing
and just enjoy the process
all right
everybody's been where you're at
okay yet look at how many people are on
the planet all right so it's not
hopeless whatever you do don't join one
of those stupid [__] in-cell groups
because those people are doomed for
failure
you have [__]
i just don't for the life of me i don't
understand where if you had a [__]
problem why you would go into a chat
room where everybody else has the same
problem
but no but there's no solution
you know what i mean like if you [__]
it'd be like me you know with all my
problems with technology if i went to a
chat room if i could find the [__]
thing and just talk to a bunch of other
old [__] guys that were born
for [__] 30 years before cell phones
even came out and we all sat around i
don't know they [__] work either i
mean how are you going to solve your
problem
uh
anyway you know what i would do
the sex industry is 100 bad i would if i
was [__] the president i would i
would i would
that incel [__] would be over quick
i'd figure out who all those [__]
in-cell kids were and i would send
[__]
horse
[__] horse
to act like they're regular people and
just go up to him and start talking to
him in the grocery store like they did
with that one guy
who was running for office and they were
trying to get dirt on him and they were
trying to get these [__] to bang him
and he [__]
wouldn't touch him and then they sent
guys they're like maybe he's gay and
then that didn't work
and he was just they thought he was like
[__] asexual
what was that guy the one who they said
[__] up the the um
the election in the year 2000 i love how
they blamed him and not al gore
um
[Laughter]
my turn
um anyways that is the podcast everybody
um
hope you guys have a great couple of
days i'll check in on you on thursday
uh miss hanukkah come and gone i hope
you had a happy hanukkah how many don't
spell it chanukah anymore
i was trying to find out at his uh
chanukah that's how they used it was
like a car there was alternate spellings
of it
uh woman 84 killed after tornado touches
down in charles county can you imagine
living for 84 [__] years
that's what gets you
a [__] tornado does that make any
goddamn sense
what are the odds at 84 you're gonna get
killed by a tornado you figure 84
stroke dementia [__] uh fallen in the
shower
who would think a goddamn twister would
take you out
jesus christ what a [__] way to go
i'll tell you right now they don't they
i'll tell you i'll tell you right now
they don't have a [__] uh i've fallen
and i gotten getting up for [__] old
people after tornado
that is the scariest
like where do you go
i literally think they have basements in
the middle of the [__] like kansas
and [__] because of tornadoes not for
extra [__]
oh my god and then you go down there
and you're just waiting for that thing
to pass by
he's just sitting down they're going why
am i keeping all of this [__]
you know
and then the second you think that
mother nature's like well i'll help you
with that
just vacuums up your whole house
you ever read these stories where people
like got sucked up into them and they
like [__]
saw [__] this [__] guy gets sucked up
in one said lightning was happening
inside of it it's like let me get this
straight you were in a tornado with your
eyes open
did you have your hands behind your head
just sitting there laying back all right
well [__] it man if you're gonna suck me
up in it wait i gotta look that up
man
inside
tornado you know that [__] they get
sucked out of their [__] house
man carried away by tornado
oh here's one we are in a tornado
oh my god
you're not in a tornado it's right next
to your house
in the though this is home video here
showing that tornado that moved through
north texas yesterday evening a friend
of mayor al assad says he shot this
video after his roof inside his home
caved in there's lightning the wind
talls
[Music]
i mean when you're in a tornado i
evidently all you can do is just yell
the obvious oh we're in a tornado
jesus christ
[__] ripped the roof off of his
[__] house
and this guy's still filming
can you imagine that can you imagine
liking instagram that much
you know what i should stay down in my
basement
with this old grandfather clock
or what if i went upstairs
and i started filming and just screaming
i'm in a tornado
you imagine how many hits i would get
when i was looking up there was a guy a
long time ago i remember reading like in
readers
digest yes a man was swept up by a
tornado
all right this is 15 years ago to the
day
matt sutter was thrown
1370 feet
in 2006 19 year old kid that's why he
got up he was 19.
uh
matt sutter was 19 years old when he had
an experience that he will never forget
he survived being swept up inside a
tornado
there's been a few stories like this but
this one was different
uh
let's see there was a severe weather
outbreak in the missouri ozarks
on march 12 2006 that lasted throughout
the evening more than a dozen tornadoes
a supercell
claiming the lives of two people but
matt was lucky as an ef2 whatever that
means tornado ripped through his
grandmother's mobile home in ford land
that evening and sutter was swept up
inside the twister records show sutter
was unconscious during this time oh yeah
but because he had been struck in the
head by a lamp
in the motorhome or a foreman grill god
knows what else he had in there
because he was struck in the head by
everything he ever owned
uh sutter woke up in a grassy field
sometimes later after being thrown over
a barbed wire fence
luckily suffer only sutter only suffered
a head injury from the lamp
and his feet were badly scratched
by what the [__] house cat clinging
to him
sutter woke up
feet roughly a quarter of a mile away
15 years later the distance still holds
the guinness book of world record for
longest distance anyone has been thrown
by a tornado and survived
i'll tell you right now i chase
tornadoes and i'm out here to break the
15 year old record
of matt sutter
of 1
370 feet
307 feet excuse me
safe to say this is one record no one
will want to break are you [__]
kidding me
are you kidding me did you see all those
[__] lining up to try and [__] flavor
flav you're telling me he's one of these
[__] people doesn't want to try to
break that record you can find somebody
um
all right that's it everybody that's the
podcast go [__] yourselves and i'll
check in on you on thursday